all right and I saved the best for last
and that's the 49ers y'all know what
type of game this is this is a playoff
uh contention
um this is a huge game huge uh not it's
uh NFC matchup y'all know it's gonna
come down to the wire
um it's gonna be a very good game
um and
I already told y'all Brock Purdy is the
real deal I mean
Brock Purdy has dominated he has not
lost a regular season game yet we have
our hands full
um yeah I know who they have they have
Christian McCaffrey who just want to
absurd last week LeBron even shouted
this man now when you get a shout out
from LeBron LeBron's random tweets you
know you are Hooper I mean this is I
mean look at what Christian McCaffrey
did against the uh Arizona Cardinals
four touchdowns I mean bro I mean
christerman Caffrey's the best back in
the NFL he can do everything he's in the
past he's in the Run uh it's gonna be
extreme matchup and you see IU you they
got Debo they got Trent Williams and
Brock Purdy keeps proving himself week
and week out dominating doing what he do
um the question is will we have uh Brock
party his first loss to the season
that's something we don't know that's
why we let the pass talk we let football
talk for us and it goes things like that
this is going to be a very good game and
especially it's at the place where we
lost that
um I think it's gonna be defensive game
as always we gotta come come in there
find a way to make uh Purdy
one-dimensional and be dominant but you
know I think he's a good quarterback uh
it's gonna be super fun to watch and I
need every Cowboys Nation I need y'all
to pull up to the bank we need to make
this a home game I'm calling Cowboys
Nation now to step up and be with us in
the bay we need every single one of
y'all we need to go up another notch we
need to be the best baby we need Cowboys
Nation there I need all of y'all there
we're going to need all hands aboard to
knock this team out
um and that's just what it's gonna take